[Musica]
pinocchio
cos'è sta roba esplode che cosa sono se
io puzzo di voto con questo video mi
faccio male questo devo fare dove trai
armi sulle uova no con il problema devo
pregare sulle uova
devo fare il mio ometto delle frittate
appare nola non lo faccio comunque no io
devo salire qua
devi sapere i piedi siete pazzi o morirò
[Musica]
adesso deve sedere sta meditando su 200
uova perché le uova sono capaci di
sorreggere grande corpo questa cosa qua
e scienza totò che battere molto piano
perché un po catarsi sotto però comunque
sia 200 uova sorreggono peso di dottore
che non essere molto ma essere tanto per
uomo incredibile no scienza perché le
uova fanno anche esperimenti noi oggi
fare esperimenti su uova o giocatore
pare esperimento molto molto simpatico
con altro materiale importante per vita
di uomo e di essere viventi nuovo
tutorial oggi pare esperimento chiamato
uovo rimbalzante torre scappare questo
necessitare di evidenziatore anzi
interno di evidenziare da tutti gli
angoli e noi prendere uovo normale e
fare diventare palla per magic johnson
come fare questa cosa
dottore aprire uovo è inserire
all'interno scherzare dottore prendere
prima aceto che essere qua e inserire
dentro bicchiere perché accetto essere
presidente
ingrediente fondamentale per fare
esperimento quindi totò reinserire
accetta in bicchiere per adesso il nuovo
indicatore fare è inserire portava mai
fatto un casino
scusami dottor essere preso con cinta
fattori tutorial adesso dove inserire
uomo senza aprirlo internamente all
aceto in questo modo
adesso tutto reinserire evidenziato anzi
interno di evidenziatore all'interno di
brodaglia esso si appena creata adesso
parte cruciale di esperimento dottore
dovrà aspettare 24 ore prima di vedere
un risultato quindi totò aspettavi e
oggi avere il risultato finale che sarei
qua davanti ai miei occhi oggi dove far
vedere cosa incredibile evidenziatore
avere generato insieme ad accesso tutto
questo casino dove inserire ma anno qua
dentro a fare veramente schifo o dottore
avere uovo molle molto molle però prima
di testare uovo pulire un attimo perché
pare proprio schifo
dottor avere asciugato uovo che essere
misticamente diventato morbido guardare
tutto per poter schiacciare questo uovo
benissimo totale fa vedere che uomo per
rimbalzare anche essere veramente magico
prova essere molto particolare essere
gioco per bambini vabbè con questo toro
essere riusciti prima parte di
sperimento essere già una cosa
incredibile
adesso passare a prossimo step dottore
fare diventare luogo il pulsante più
grosso tutto ciò che prendere uovo che
gia e sarei diventato molle far rivedere
rimbalzo perché saremo molto bello
mettere mi piace per rimbalzato dover
prendere sciroppo d'acero risalire
sciroppo d'acero all'interno di altro
bicchiere dottore inserire uovo rimbalzo
zoe all'interno di sciroppo d'acero
in questo modo qua e nera all'interno di
sciroppo d'acero uomo per 24 ore piene
una volta finito poi prende ruolo in
sterline dentro un altro bicchiere pieno
di acqua e di colorante alimentare e
tenere per altre 24 ore
una volta finito anche questo
procedimento è stabilmente sai concluso
adesso tocca a farmi vedere risultato
finale è avere uovo finale perché essere
carta ningyo essere qua all'interno di
bicchiere
eccolo qua essere diventato gigantesco
uovo di struzzo e sarebbe molto
importante adesso dove andare a pulire
anche questo
[Musica]
per avere quindi uovo che rispetto
all'inizio essere molle quindi rimbalzo
ed essere anche uovo più adesso noi dopo
tutto questo casino fare ancora un altro
esperimento storia passare a un altro
esperimento con uovo adesso una cosa un
po strana c'è renderle uovo pallina da
ping pong che pare questa cosa totò è
dovere inserire soltanto guscio di uovo
all'interno di aceto per ventiquattr'ore
sempre a farmi questo dottore dover
svuotare uovo all'interno come svuotare
nuovo all'interno dottore dovere bucare
con spilla luogo soprattutto sotto e poi
fischiare dentro l'uovo farlo uscire
tutto e tenersi in carcere
[Musica]
adesso totò con sua boccuccia fischiare
all'interno di nuovo papà ad uscire
tutto
è vero
[Musica]
adesso passare al secondo step devono
inserire all'interno di bicchiere vuoto
aceto e poi inserire solo guscio perché
adesso ci sono un dottore inserire
adesso lasciarle uovo all'interno dei
100 per 24 ore
una volta finite 24 ore l'avallo bene e
lasciarlo seccare adesso dottori e farvi
vedere esperimento riuscito perché
pallina da ping pong essa si creata da
uovo ed essere in mano di totò che
adesso questo uovo rimbalzare come
pallina da ping pong quindi può
funzionare
adesso totoro e mettere a confronto
tutti quanti uova che hai fatto
esperimenti di oggi quindi prova gli
esperimenti grazie dottore aver radunato
davanti a sé finale di esperimenti primo
uovo normale quindi uomo a posto secondo
nuovo mole essere fluorescente vedere
qua terzo luogo essere uovo essere solo
blu grosso è e sarà anche questo
rimbalzo zoe infine avere l'uomo più
strana di tutti che è nuovo e poter
mettere qua gusci di uova e sarà
composto in gran parte da carbonato di
calcio stessa sostanza che comporre
kalkar aceto conteneva acido che reagire
con carbonato di calcio rendere guscio
soli le sue dissolversi piano piano una
volta 18 completamente a rimanere strato
superficiale membrana di nuovo che
essere e la foto questa nevada essere
semipermeabile vuol dire che poteva far
passare di una certa quantità di acqua
per questo immergersi muovo
sperimentale a base di acqua nuovo
collocarsi e aumentare i volumi
ok adesso facciamo la figura di nuovo
che mi metto quello lo sciroppo d'acero
località asti con i presenti che rischia
se questo nel finale di esperimento
dottore rivelare realtà che essere
seguente nuovo grosso perché essere
rimesso in sciroppo d'acero sciroppo
d'acero essere come tutta di iron man e
rendere l'uomo invincibile guardare
[Musica]
se mi chiede ma io lo sapevo che
succederà stato lo sapevo mannaggia la
pupazza stato ricordarvi che prossime
estati mente essere 24 dicembre vigilia
di natale esperimento speciali non
mancare puntate incredibile voi se avete
tempo libero e ce l'avete perché dottore
sapere tutto avere playlist di
esperimenti incredibile qua sopra che
potete cliccare per vedere tutti al
trasferimento oppure verrà attribuito un
momento molto bello essere qua in basso
oppure se aver visto tutto ma voi non
avere visto tutto quindi guardare
comunque qua pensarci canale
iscrivetevi canale il patto è e noi ci
vediamo al prossimo esperimento